Let's talk about how to perform passive
Network Traffic Management. One way to do
this is using the Packet and Byte
Counters provided by the Simple Network Management Protocol.
Many network devices provide what's called a
Management Information Base, or a MIB that can
be polled or queried for particular information.
One common use for SNMP is to pull
a particular Interface on a Network Device. For
the number of Bytes or Packets that it sent.
By periodically polling, we can then determine the rate
at which Traffic is being sent on a link
by simply taking the difference in these Packet
and Byte Counters over particular intervals. The advantage of
SNMP is that it's fairly ubiquitous. It's supported on
essentially all Networking Equipment and there are many products
for polling and analysing SNMP data. On the other
hand, it's fairly coarse and you can not express
complex queries on the data. It's coarse in the
sense that because we are just polling Byte or
Packet Counts on the Interface. We can't ask specific
questions, such as how much Traffic has been sent
by a particular host or by a particular flow.
Two other ways to measure passively are by monitoring
at a packet granularity, whereby monitors can see full packet
contents or at least headers. Or at a flow level where a
monitor may see specific statistics about individual flows in the network.
Let's now talk a little bit about packet and Flow Monitoring.